pues lo que está diciendo es comer que
es el líder de la minoría demócrata en
el senado en la cámara alta es que una
vez pues se vote en la cámara alta el
impeachment si es que se aprueba en la
cámara alta en el senado pues después de
que sea aprobado el impeachment en el
senado habrá otro voto que propondrán
los demócratas que ya tendrán mayoría
por los dos votos que llegue el de
sumaron a su lista de senadores en el
senado y entonces ese voto que consigo
se tratará entonces de pues evitar de
que don otro pueda reelegirse en el 2024
nosotros sin embargo ha dicho en
ocasiones anteriores que si no es el van
a ser sus hijos o sus asesores más
allegados se ha mencionado incluso la
posibilidad de que ivanka trump pues
llegue también a ser candidata en el
por otro lado mitch mcconnell pues dijo
precisamente eso que ustedes presionaba
que lo primero que va a hacer el
congreso y el senado una vez se instale
19 de noviembre empiece otra vez sus
funciones después del receso en el que
ésta es precisamente pues y debatir esta
información este pedido de impeachment
que le llega de la cámara de
representantes de los demócratas que hoy
votaron por segunda vez hacerle el
juicio político a tonos o cristóbal le
pregunto si precisamente hay reacciones
del presidente saliente donald trump y
de los republicanos ante esto
y horas antes de que se conociera el
veredicto de la cámara de
representantes- la decisión de hacerle
juicio político por segunda vez el
presidente de donald trump pues y el
presidente saliente escribió un
comunicado pidiéndole a sus
simpatizantes bajar las tensiones calma
pidió no recurrir a la violencia en las
manifestaciones que posiblemente se
darán antes de la posesión el 20 de
enero manifestaciones por trump
nuevamente en la capital pidió no
vandalismo y pidió unión algo parecido a
lo que pidió el vicepresidente pensa
ayer en su carta a la cámara de
representantes
cristóbal gracias buena noche